the Zika virus could spread to four
million people this year
so what is it it was discovered in
Uganda in the 1940s then detected in a
few other places over the years it broke
out in the Americas and the Caribbean in
Zika is transmitted through a particular
species of mosquito that lives mostly in
tropical regions that includes parts of
the US whose evidence that the virus
could be transmitted through other means
to Zika has been linked to paralysis and
birth defects Brazil has seen a spike in
babies born with a certain kind of brain
damage officials are now warning
pregnant women not to travel to places
where there's an active Zika outbreak
generally though Zika symptoms are mild
and most people infected don't notice
anything there is no treatment for the
virus and officials say finding a
vaccine could take up to a decade